presented by those two players donovan  mitchell goes to team durant  and rudy gobert goes to  team lebron  i just i just want to say something  because there's no  slander  you guys got to understand just like in  video games growing up  we never played with utah even as great  as carl malone and john stockton  we would have never picked those guys in  video games never  look this is the video game hold on  we got to leave it right there we got to  take it out now you can say something  lebron says i really need some size  and he got seven five four bears right  and he goes with six two sabonis  killing me oh you can i i was like i  need some sides  he takes a six two guys  nobody plays video games i just knew he  was going to go back